serr
[Applaudissements]
descendre les gens
qui doucement doucement doucement
doucement très très très
doucement le temps de bien travailler
son truc il y en a plein qui sèchent
aussi de l'autre côté de la route tiens
c'est assez marrant attends que je
regarde un truc
non il y a personne à côté c'est un peu
dommage
c'est un peu mort ça non un
peu en fait il y en a plein les rues du
du L qui par là ouis j'ai vu
c'est marrant dans les dans les brousail
de
milieu pantalons qui sèchz
rigolo pour moi c'est be
tout pantalons étal par
terre
tuas serré un peu làdedans ou pas
attends je fais je termine
truc descends pas plus oua mais là je
touche le
bras un mec qui est en train d'en
étaler
très joli c'est les pantalons qui sont
er oui ser ser les pantalons qui sont
tout seul sur une petite île au milieu
ouais ouais
ouais
voilà bon je sais pas si
c'est
qui va
rentrer c'est bien ça
que
VI
rouge
i r
R
s de non att
[Musique]
termine
inf arrive le
linge les
parasitéc
oreilles
couleur c'est
quoi sa sur
des c'est bon c'est
bon
pouroi
ok pe couper